elbers glaub jetzt willkommen beim ein
video ich hab halt mal wieder den
herbstwald wir waren ja haben wir das
schon mal ein video zusammen gedreht
und er macht ein bisschen friseur sachen
und ich hab ich will einfach meine haare
und bisschen anders haben als ich muss
er wieder zum friseur und da haben wir
das machen wir wieder raus es gibt auch
meinem channel m für seinen schönen aber
was gedreht das ist dann der video
beschreibung verlinkt und am ende auch
aber jetzt erstmal hier meine haare
fährt mal gucken hat wir machen diese
bisher blonden haarsträhnen rein und
dann mal gucken was bei rumkommen wer
ist die schweiz aus ich habe voll angst
aber ein anfang
meine seiten sind auf jeden fall
sollte oben die so lassen also solange
lassen damit ich nicht immer hoch machen
muss und jetzt werden die bisschen
blonder also nicht so überall aber
bisher kommt es jetzt das was machst du
jetzt kommen gleich nochmals die seiten
mit der schere noch mal ein echtes
bleibt dass wir jetzt blau
er meint das ist immer so
videos
insofern hilft es sollte ich einfach so
lassen
würdest du jetzt 500.000 euro darf
werden das blockiert ja ok
schippmann
ich bin echt ich bin jetzt war positiv
überrascht man könnte meinen ihr könnt
eure meinung
eure meinung in die kommentare wenn ihr
es gut findet macht es einfach so ist
mir jetzt einfach auf die wertung wenn
es gut findet gibt ein daumen nach oben
und wenn ihr es nicht gut findet gibt
einfach noch nach unten
mit
heute jetzt bevor jetzt sagt zu bohren
sieht volkshaus also ich bin eigentlich
okay also ich finde es voll okay so soll
jetzt einfach mal testen wächst ja auch
wieder raus dann muss man sich natürlich
erst dran gewöhnen ist natürlich klar
auf jeden fall schickt auf jeden fall
seinen kanal ab ist ganz oben in der
video beschreibung verlinkt und das auf
jeden fall bei ihm aber dann macht er
macht ihm also 5000 fall ist bei 4.000
jetzt dann hat der 5000 ich muss ganz
auf meine haare achten und wir haben
auch noch ein video gedreht deswegen
schotter auf jeden fall mal vorbei
abonniert ihn bitte werk cool also wie
genau wie beim letzten mal ein videos
wieder auf seinem kanal eins wieder bei
mir dann ja ansonsten würde ich sagen
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen